hi there we had this question on our ai
coffee break quiz recently and we must
discuss its answer here because we never
had such a contested question before on
our quiz so if you do not know what i'm
talking about here follow miss coffee
bean to the community tab of this
channel because we have quite the set of
machine learning related quiz questions
and the new question is coming each day
but let's get to our question about the
sequence length of the transformer it's
not a simple question not gonna lie the
answer depends a bit on how one reads it
christian garcia noted very well that
transformers do not process just
sequences but something more general a
sequence without order which is a set
the sequential nature of the data
becomes clear to the transformer only
because we add positional embeddings to
encode the order in which the data comes
in if it is the case for more about this
check out some of our previous videos
but supposing we are processing a
sequence with a given model for example
sequence of words does the sequence
always have to have the same length or
can this length vary
and it's a valid question because there
are architectures like convolutional
architectures with a fully connected
layer in the end where the input must
have always the same size if the image
is not the right size it gets resized
during pre-processing so we want to
answer this question for the transformer
in two ways first by looking into the
code and then theoretically because well
one just does not need to play around a
lot with a transformer from hugging
phase to notice that inputs which have
different lengths are possible so yes
the things we want to process with a
transformer can have variable lengths
the tokenizer just gives us more token
ids as output and an attention mask full
of ones but with more ones as the
sequence grows bigger but because of the
quadratically scaling attention in
compute we also notice parameters in the
transformers library limiting the
sequence length which has the effect of
truncating everything which exceeds that
length to keep memory and computation in
bounds looking at the bird tokenizer
documentation we also see the pad token
and its explanation by padding the
sequence to a maximum length we can
produce inputs of fixed length for the
transformer even when the sequence is
shorter than the maximum length our
input length has always the same size
because the sequence is padded with the
pad token and the attention mask is
padded with zeros and all this trouble
is for efficiency reasons in the
implementation when we want to train or
do inference on more than just one
sample at once because in that case
tensors in a batch should have the same
size such that the gpu can handle this
efficiently therefore the answer to this
question of whether transformers process
sequences of a predefined length or a
variable length is both yes and no
yes sequence length can vary as in yes
the transformer can process any length
but also
no because efficient implementations fix
the length to a maximum length anyway
but in principle and i think that it is
the most important thing about
transformers if everything with
positional encodings and training works
well for every sequence length there's
no reason for why transformers should be
bound to a specific set size or sequence
length because the feed forward layers
we see here are the same no matter the
position of the token we are looking at
so even if we add here one more token at
the end this does not care as we take
the same feed forward module and its
weights and apply them on the newly
added tokens and the attention is also
not caring about the sequence length as
it just computes a pairwise score given
a vector and another vectors so it just
looks at vector pairs at a time
therefore miss coffee bean would rather
say that transformers process sequences
of variable length in principle
okay bye
[Music]
[Music]
you